- [Narrator] Cross-gender
dancing is when the roles
of both the female and
male are played by one man.
Using costumes, masks and movement,
the dancers are able to easily transition
between the two-gendered
characters they are playing.
In the past, males would play female roles
in performances and plays and
although women are now allowed
to perform, through those old rules,
this new dance was born.
(speaking in foreign language)
The dance moves themselves are mostly
traditional Indonesian styles.
Didik takes time
perfecting female movement
so his transitions can appear
as authentic as possible.
Today, Didik travels the
world teaching people
about this form of dance,
preserving the culture
and tradition for future generations.
And in doing so, he's making a difference
and erasing the stigmas the dancers faced.
(soft music)